So Katie, you look a little bit fatigued at this point.
>> We've done an awful lot.
Yeah. >> How many lessons?
>> About to start the 15th, so.
>> Oh, my god.
>> But I wouldn't say that there's 15 totally separate topics.
I'd say that there's maybe more like four main topics.
>> Okay, what are they?
The first one is the data set and question.
If you want to use machine learning, can you define a question and
find the data could help you answer it?
>> I guess the second one is feature selection,
finding the right feature spaces for your machine learning algorithm to apply?
>> Once you have the features, do you have an algorithm that you can use, and
the parameter chains you want for that algorithm?
>> And finally the fourth step is validation.
Make sure what you've got is actually trustworthy.
>> And of course, these steps, you won't just hit each of them once.
But you'll cycle through them repeatedly as you start to figure out a little bit
more about each individual question,
you learn more, and you do a little bit better.
>> So in this last and final unit, in this last and
final unit, you put the big picture together.
We're going to go up to a higher altitude and learn big picture composition of
machine learning, so you actually apply these techniques in practice.
>> So let's head up to that higher level.